regardez cet objet regardez le bien
je suis persuadé que presque
instinctivement vous avez devinez de
quoi il s'agit oui c'est bien une
aiguille achats qui servait avec du fil
pour coudre et assembler des pièces de
cuir mais la particularité de celle ci
c'est son âge elle a plus de quinze
mille ans vous vous rendez compte quinze
mille ans ce sont près de 600 génération
humaine qui nous sépare d'elle et
pourtant sa forme et sa fonction n'ont
pas changé seule sa matière s'est
transformé le métal s'étend aujourd'hui
substituer à loos c'est l'exemple type
d'une invention brillante qui n'a eu nul
besoin de se perfectionner au cours du
temps pour garder son efficacité elle
est aussi là pour nous illustrer que les
hommes du paléolithique les hommes de la
préhistoire sont encore ancré
aujourd'hui dans nos civilisations dans
le sens où nous utilisons encore de nos
jours certains de leurs outils
vous serez d'accord avec moi pour dire
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes entourés de
technologies toutes plus innovantes les
unes que les autres
et parmi les éléments qui les
caractérise il existe un phénomène
puissant de miniaturisation
nous sommes entourés de micro
technologies et des mondes des
télécommunications et de l'informatique
le montre bien
nos téléphones portables par exemple en
sont un exemple parfait taille réduite
puissance accrue nos ordinateurs sont
toujours plus légers et plus sûrs plus
mobile plus haut plus performant notre
santé dépendra sans doute demain des
nanotechnologies qui se développe à
vitesse grand v et font l'objet
d'investissements financiers colossaux
ça vous allez me dire c'est connu de
toutes et tous et vous pourriez penser
quel rapport avec notre aiguilles achat
du début et la préhistoire en général et
bien ce que vous ne saviez peut être pas
c'est que la miniaturisation est un
phénomène technologique anciens et
qu'elle nous fait remonter au plus
profond de nos ancêtres dans l'étang
paléolithique
nous allons avec aujourd'hui remonter le
temps et voir quelle était la quelle a
été la première miniaturisation
technologique de l'humanité elle prend
place donc au cours de la préhistoire
avec les premières sociétés d'homo
sapiens mais dans un premier temps
demandant nous qui est homo sapiens homo
sapiens désigne des hommes et des femmes
qui comme vous et moi sont
biologiquement et anatomiquement
identique à nous notre espèce humaine
apparaît quelque part en afrique entre
300 et 200 mille ans avant le présent à
un moment où d'autres espèces humaines
peuple et encore le globe
dans d'autres régions du monde en
eurasie par exemple à partir d'un peu
plus de cent mille en homo sapiens
commence un grand voyage il passe
d'abord par le proche orient puis la
péninsule arabique
il atteint l'australie il y environ
65000 ans et s'installe en europe à peu
près aux alentours de 45 mille ans avant
nos jours au cours de ce long voyage
homo sapiens va remplacer toutes les
autres espèces humaines qui l'avaient
précédé c'est ce qui explique
qu'aujourd'hui nous soyons la seule
espèce humaine sur terre et les derniers
survivants de la longue évolution
humaine
au cours de ce périple qui durera à peu
près 80 milles en homo sapiens va
développer des technologies innovantes
il va multiplier les expressions
symbolique il va inventer l'art
figuratif et parmi les cultures
matériels qui vont l'accompagner parmi
ces outils du quotidien qui vont le
suivre il va faire des inventions et une
de ses inventions va marquer l'histoire
de l'humanité c'est un objet miniature
un véritable little big tool qui a
hérité d'une importance cruciale pour la
vie de nos ancêtres l'objet dont nous
allons parler aujourd'hui est donc un
objet miniature c'est une lamelle en
silex à première vue rien
d'impressionnant mais cette lamelle en
silex possède des propriétés qui nous
allons essayer de le voir a eu des
conséquences remarquable c'est donc un
objet de forme très stéréotypé obtenu
selon des méthodes qui vous demanderai
une bonne dose d'apprentissage et de
savoir faire pour réussir à en produire
c'est aussi un objet de taille très
réduite qui fait entre 1 et 2 cm de long
très léger avec des propriétaires gogui
ergonomique remarquable la
miniaturisation constitue donc une
tendance de fond dans l'évolution des
techniques
elle a eu lieu partout elle émerge avec
homo sapiens sapiens en afrique et va se
répandre comme une traînée de poudre à
travers la planète
les questions qui se posent aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que cette miniaturisation
nous fait penser aux miniaturisation que
l'on peut vivre actuellement dans le
monde contemporain que ce soit en
robotique ou en informatique et des
chercheurs ou des philosophes des
techniques se sont interrogés à savoir
est ce que chaque ligne et technique
possède en elle des propriétés
particulières qui font que toute forme
tendrait vers une certaine logique de
miniaturisation les questions sur
lesquelles on va se pencher c'est donc
d'examiner et d'essayer de trouver des
éléments de réponse sur pourquoi cette
forme de miniaturisation se produit il
ya plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'années
et en quoi elle peut expliquer ou
contribuer à expliquer le succès
adaptatif planétaire qu'ont connu les
homo sapiens que nos ancêtres directs
ont connu alors plusieurs raisons
complémentaires évidemment peuvent être
avancées d'abord il y a des raisons
techniques il faut savoir que ces
petites lamelles ces objets miniatures
sont des éléments d'armes de chasse des
éléments d'armes de chasse complexe et
composites qui comme on le voit à
l'image associe souvent des sags et en
bois végétales des pointes en hausse et
ces petites lamelles qui viennent
renforcer le caractère vulnérant et
l'efficacité de larmes
ce faisant les homo sapiens il ya
plusieurs dizaines de milliers d'années
se situe d'emblée dans une recherche en
ergonomie en aéro balistique pour
trouver les meilleures propriétés et
faire voler des armes légères
l'intérêt c'est que ce faisant il se met
à distance des proies chassé en
inventant de nouveaux modes de chasse à
l'aide du propulseur puis ensuite d'arc
qui constitue la première machine de
l'histoire de l'humanité
cela leur permet donc de se mettre à
distance des troupeaux cela leur permet
de diversifier les animaux qu'il chasse
cela leur permet ce faisant de
diversifier leur régime alimentaire
voilà pour les raisons techniques mais
il ya aussi des raisons économiques car
ces objets sont miniature ils sont donc
très léger et facilement transportable
donc ils sont particulièrement adaptés
pour des sociétés de chasseurs
cueilleurs collector nomades qui ont un
nomadisme et des formes de nomadisme qui
leur demandent des circulations sur de
vastes territoires en fonction de cycles
saisonniers et enfin il ya des raisons
sociales car cette miniaturisation va
arriver à un moment où les sociétés
spécialistes de plus en plus leur
outillage les outils deviennent plus en
plus spécialisés sur des tâches
spécifiques
or qui dit spécialisation des outils
dits sans doute spécialisation des
acteurs qui les manipulent et donc une
certaine forme d' expertise qui se met
en place
certaines personnes ont des propriétés
et des tâches spécifiques dans le groupe
que d'autres ne sache ne savent pas
faire par exemple on assiste aux
premiers experts expert en taille de la
pierre experts chasseurs expert en art
car c'est aussi la période de
l'émergence de l'art qui boit net de
véritable artiste accompli on voit donc
très rapidement que cette
miniaturisation des outils n'est pas un
simple fait technique et qu elle nous
emmène bien au delà
au niveau technique on assiste à la
minute avec la miniaturisation à une
importance accrue placés sur des grandes
technologies technologies très avancées
pour le succès de la chasse on voit là
le parallèle est peut-être un peu
caricatural mais miniaturisation
technologie de pointe ça peut nous
rappeler nos microprocesseurs par
exemple on assiste à des mobilités
beaucoup plus accrue que pendant les
périodes précédentes donc des peuples
beaucoup plus mobile qui circulent sur
de bien plus vaste territoire
on assiste donc pendant ces périodes à
des peuples qui sont interconnectés les
uns avec les autres sur de très grandes
distances avec la création de grands
réseaux des changes
cela permet à la fois l'échangé des
biens mais également des personnes
c'est-à-dire que les personnes sont de
plus en plus en contact d'un clan à un
autre et cela souligne vraisemblablement
avec homo sapiens un changement dans les
règles exogames hic dans les règles de
parenté c'est à dire qu'on va chercher
partenaires en dehors de son clan ce qui
est un phénomène majeur pour connaître
l'expansion démographique a connu
sapiens par rapport aux espèces
précédente
et enfin on a un nouvel ordre social qui
se met en place avec l'émergence de
spécialistes dans certains domaines et
vraisemblablement d individu détenteur
d'un certain prestige et donc une
certaine forme de stratification sociale
on le voit là qu'avec un objet simple en
apparence ce little big toul
on est entraînés bien au delà sur les
questions d origine de sapiens sur les
questions des raisons qui expliqueraient
le succès planétaire qu'a connues notre
espèce de façon un petit peu
complémentaire on pourrait également
dire que ça explique les raisons qui
viennent à soir l'extinction de toutes
les autres espèces humaines qui avait
été représentée auparavant c'est là pour
dire qu'un fait technique est un fait
social total et qu' on pourrait dire que
avant de comprendre une innovation avant
de comprendre une invention il faut
qu'elle soit comprise par le groupe
acceptée par le groupe avant que celle
ci d'une invention géniale deviennent
innovation et puisse se diffuser
et je pense qu'à un moment où on vit une
crise écologique comme actuellement à un
moment où on s'interroge si notre
société ne va pas dans le mur
et si l'humanité n'est pas face à un mur
un petit peu abrupte on ferait bien de
multiplier l'examen des situations
passées car on se ressent on se rendrait
sans guide compte qu'à chaque fois que
des inventions géniales de se produisent
c'est toute une gamme et une somme de
contraintes qui se met en place et que
la société doit d'accepter voilà et en
guise de clin d'oeil pour finir penser à
chaque fois que vous ferez un peu de
couture la prochaine fois que vote
régulier achats à plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d'années et que sans doute sans
elle nous ne serions pas là aujourd'hui
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]